Je veux vous demander de quelle partie du
pays vous venez du
Canada, je suppose que c'est bien, je sais que
nous y sommes en quelque sorte, j'y suis allé
moi-même bien voyagé pour l'esclave Solomon
Northup est un joueur expert du
violon  Je suis né un homme libre vivant avec
ma famille à New York sois bon pour ta
mère
jusqu'au jour où je devais voir Salomon
kidnappé vendu en esclavage eh bien mon garçon comment
tu te sens maintenant je m'appelle Solomon Northup
je suis un homme libre et toi  n'a aucun droit
de me détenir tu sais
homme libre tu n'es rien d'autre qu'un fugitif de Géorgie
nous sommes au bord de la rivière Géorgie
servons le n'obéis pas est le Seigneur sera
battu de plusieurs coups c'est l'
Ecriture la condition de tes ouvriers
c'est  tout faux suis-je la propriété vous
dites qu'avec fierté je dis que c'est un grand
homme fait ce qu'il veut avec son
stand de propriété
vous venez ici monsieur venez ici il y a quelques jours
j'étais avec ma famille et ma maison maintenant vous
me dites toute cette perte si vous  vouloir
survivre faire et dire le moins possible
Isola surgissant quand j'ouvre le survivant
pendant un an et tu es l'un d'eux
je pensais que tu savais quelque chose que j'ai fait comme
indiqué il y a quelque chose qui ne
va pas avec le maître d'instruction
t'a acheté ici pour travailler plus t'apprendre
cent coups je sais ce que c'est  aime être
l'objet de masses en son
temps bon lot de demain je survivrai
je ne tomberai pas dans le désespoir Oh
donc père ne te nourris pas de cette opportunité
j'étais un homme libre
je ne suis rien
[Musique]